We're going to build
quantum circuits like this out of some of the arithmetic operations we talked about earlier in the lesson.
And by doing that, we
give quantum circuits the ability to evaluate those operations on super positions of classical states.
And as we will see, that allows us to factor integers efficiently.
That's the end of this lesson, which has focused mainly on establishing a foundation
for quantum algorithms in a standard non-black box
computational framework.
We talked about computational cost mainly through the lens of problems connected with basic number theory.
We discussed polynomial
versus exponential cost for computational tasks, and we saw how classical computations
can be implemented by quantum circuits in a clean garbage-free manner that allows them to be used as subroutines
inside of larger quantum computations.
I hope you'll join me for the next lesson where we'll see how Shor's algorithm puts these ideas to use, allowing us to factorize
integers at polynomial cost.
Goodbye until then.